[Music]
there's a new story I can't stop
thinking about well that's not true this
is on a card I don't care
Mitt Romney recently revealed to the
Atlantic that he has a secret Twitter
account under the name Pierre de lecto
more like mutt I'm asking you that
forever
oh I I thought that's what you wanted me
to do know what I keep wanting to do
which I think would kill is if I go you
know was in the news MIT Romney if he
asked me more like mutt Romney if you
whooped there went woof and why don't
you wanted to wolf no oh
kill all right killing it would catch on
every night Mitt Romney more like mutt
Romney wait what now yeah then when the
cameras on you go woof and I go low and
then we do that we do it the first night
it gets pretty good laughs and then we
keep doing it and then it becomes like
dancing Ito's it's a big thing it's a
lot to remember convinced that would be
big people would tune in to go like you
think he's gonna do it tonight and I go
you know else is in the news Mitt Romney
and people try to go they know what's
coming actually more like mutt Romney
know we got to work on it nothing I like
better than making him unhappy stymie
and O'Brien my favorite name of my book
mutt Romney recently revealed to the
Atlantic that he has a corporate Twitter
account
[Laughter]
[Applause]
oh man
[Music]